so I am truly delighted to introduce Ted
Kelly who got his PhD in 1970 from our
math department
Ted's dissertation was entitled
immersions of symmetric spaces and I'm
sure he's going to tell us all about
that his thesis was supervised by sig
helgesen who's here
Ted held academic positions for a while
and then he turned his skills to the
insurance business first joining Aetna
in 1974 in 1992
Ted was named president and chief
operating officer of Liberty Mutual
which is based in Boston and he was
elected chief executive officer in 1998
and chairman in 2000 during the 13 years
that Ted led tibberton
Liberty Mutual the the company
experienced truly dramatic growth today
there's the third largest property and
casualty insurer in the United States
headquartered here in Boston's Back Bay
and employing more than 45,000 people
across the world
Ted retired from Liberty Mutual a little
less than a year ago but continues as
chairman of the board in September 2011
Ted was named chairman of the board of
trustees for the Boston Symphony
Orchestra and in addition he's a member
of the board of directors for the Bank
of New York Mellon Corporation the EMC
Corporation in the American Ireland fund
Kelley is fellow of the Society of
Actuaries and was recently named fellow
of the American Academy of Arts and
Sciences Ted has supported MIT in a
number of ways he's a member of
President Hawk fields Advisory Council
on regional engagement and a member of
the corporation visiting committee for
the department of mathematics over the
years Liberty Mutual has supported
graduate students in the math department
with expendable fellowships and is
currently in the process of endowing a
Liberty Mutual fellowship which will
support a math graduate student in
perpetuity
these Dean's colloquia are designed to
expose the MIT community our students
and faculty and and others to people who
have really done unusual things we in
our classes we extol the virtues of
people who have won Nobel Prizes or
fields medals but it's important to
realize that great education for example
in mathematics prepares you for really
unusual accomplishments in life and
we're really delighted that ted has come
here today to tell us about his
trajectory thank you Mark and thank you
all for coming before I start there a
couple of people to want to recognize
they're pretty important to me my wife
Debbie and my daughter Sonia it's thank
them for coming soon and it's a great
honor to have sig helgesson here I'll
touch upon my talk and he's a great
influence in my life and career thank
you obviously if I sort of take the
topic it's about my trajectory this
morning my daughter called me said well
is your speech threaded I said yeah I
was born I'm still alive I'm still I'm
filling in the details something this
afternoon
and maybe I'm what I'd like to do if you
think about a person's life
it's not a perfect parabola like a
dollar was fought I mean the things as
people say life is what happens when you
have other plans and of course it's not
an essential Brownian motion where
you're sure it's they're subject to they
random molecular movement around you
you're you sort of have to take control
of it but you can't take total control
of and I respond to the things and how
you end up and sort of where I started
where I ended up but where I thought it
was going ended up very differently
maybe it's a good place I was actually
born in a you know a surah in 1945 and
sort of sort of a there's some time as I
look back in my life
I was just pre baby boomer but over that
time I was exposed as my neighbors were
to all the things that change society
and had that a significant impact in my
life and I responded to them I was born
and as I said in 45 and those who
remember that you know British Isles was
very very poor and it had gone through
two world wars and of course their
significant depression Ireland of course
was even poorer than the mainland and
the era I was born and it was very quite
quite poor
there was interesting from a
geographical oh my piss was born that
was on the place called historic health
which stands for the hidden fort about
two hundred yards from the house there
was a 3,000 year old fort from that
people fear bald who preceded the Celts
and Ireland Macross but half a mile
across the top of the hill there was a
megalith looked like a megalith actually
was a bit tall but it was a standing
stone which was pre-data Stonehenge of
course people that are just all
superstition didn't cut that he didn't
cut wood in the safe and their fort
because there was bad luck and people
are quite superstitious but almost
immediately I was exposed to the 20th
century my first memory is not evently
ah my first memory is standing in the
door of the farmhouse we had no
electricity or running water there
wasn't many in that part of the country
looking out of the farmyard and seeing
my siblings play it was a family of ten
I was the fifth and tenth as you well
know in the middle of a large family is
doomed to failure and I wasn't allowed
out to play and unless didn't I thought
memory is as clear today as you know
what I did on the way over what actually
happened was when I was about 18 months
old
I got croup which was a disease of a
viral disease of the raspberry tract and
I developed significant secondary
infections I was rushed to Belfast whose
40 miles been hospital and the doctor
told my mother stay in the hospital he
may not make it in the morning but we're
going to try a new drug I was the first
child in Belfast
to be treated with penicillin think
about that right off the top
my life was influenced by the 20th
century just a remarkable thing and the
outcome of that also an impact on other
things
my mother took a very memories because
it Irish for a but a year I was not
allowed to leave the house
my mother's free to get sick that's why
I remembered the good thing about that
was that I don't remember not being able
to read for some reason my mother claims
on his paternal exaggeration because
that possible that I taught my South
rate is not but somehow or the other she
and my father taught me to read so the
very young age I laid a letter quite a
sheltered life I went to a two room
schoolhouse my maternal grandmother and
grandfather had taught there my grand
grandmother died long before his born
and well it was poor there was no people
to worry about equipment there was we
had slits little slits with pieces of
chalk no schoolbooks but there was a
very good education system and
commitment because there was a cultural
commitment education fortunately after a
short period of time my parents sold the
farm all of 100 acres you know very very
poor and eventually we ended up in
Belfast I say fortunately for several
reasons first of all my family and my
mother insisted that I go to a school in
the center of the city it was a
Christian Brothers school in a condemned
building the no facilities the
playground was not as big as the lobby
where we met and it had phenomenal
academic success so not only did it
educate the local people in the very
very poor part of the city as people
from the suburbs came in the bus fare
public transportation was the nickel
round trip and remember frequently
walking homes we could spend two and a
half cents on candy at lunchtime might
have paid for my teeth later on but it
was it was education was pretty
important and I recall him and it was a
very good education we studied
Julius Caesar was ten years old now
there's a pretty bottle Erised version
wasn't but we had to learn friends
Romans countrymen lend me your ears ten
years open and then it off to have an
off to school and surprise surprise
early on looking back my old report
cards my best subject was not
mathematics it was English by far but it
was very fortunate it was a remarkable
school and you know it influenced
education really got me where I am so
that's why it's a property right through
all the time very very fortunate think
about it 1957 I was 12 years old in a
Catholic school in Ireland in the
algebra class and the priest community
said to me Ted Kelly what do you think
about abortion it was illegal to even
talk about in the rest of the time so I
was a very liberal I blushed it was some
it was sex and women and all that sort
of stuff I don't want to talk about it
but it was that side really broad
liberal education very unlike Madrid was
also fortunate that one of my teachers
had a master's degree in math from
Oxford Oh Cambridge so a great exposure
very very early on and typical education
British as the time we took nine courses
three languages had to write a 5 to 10
page essay in English once a week the
the English exam at 13 was a three hour
essay exam made one a these three hours
and it was a very good education so an
invention off the Queen's Belfast small
math department but it was a good math
department and I'll give two names and
one of them kind of interesting a guy
called Sam for Blonsky Sam did for their
mathematicians he did fury analysis
pretty much she was a classical analyst
he did a lot of stuff and polynomials
orthogonal polynomials in the circle and
it was pretty much forgotten and was
revived interested in his work was
revived bad guy thing cos him called
about simon simon he wrote something
10-15 years ago
Sam's but it
being British eyes we didn't have any
interplay with the professors between
class I didn't know what Sam did the
other interesting thing about Sam just
an aside
Sam everybody assumed Sam was a bachelor
and in fact I read it when preparing for
the talk I looked up on Wikipedia and as
a [ __ ] he said he's a bachelor
well it turns out that Sam had a wife he
was a total recluse and very few people
I got to know after him back and visited
Sam sort of a man that strange guy did
all that great mathematics the other guy
was a guy called ruff
no yeah ruff happenstance dog who
developed the hands talked integral
it's a subzero there there are functions
that are not too big integral but our
hands talking a little and but we didn't
know this I mean he just taught us stuff
from you know even at last you're
elected to your left the other thing of
course I did very much British as things
I did one course beside mathematics I
took a year in physics and I could have
gone on for years but I just said it out
you know after three years and I try to
come to America my father come to
America early on and Hennis came before
him didn't come back and marry my mother
heard of MIT and Samford Blonsky said
Kelly if you can get into MIT go to MIT
so I could add a my team and I remember
well my first day and they walked in and
norm Levinson was the chair of the
department oh no I had a graduate
studies head of Graduate Studies and he
said it's that done I said very very
pleasant he said well I suppose in
typical British tradition he did far too
much analysis that's an inside joke but
he did that's he said and I said what he
said you did too much analysis do
something else that was the end of the
discussion so I signed up for Don
quillin's geometry course which we over
my head the way ahead of signed up for
different courses that signed up for
customs uh
maybe next year Lee groups and I got
started and then one day I drifted in
there's this
Icelandic guy I heard was doing great
mathematics and I just said incentive
second year in a course in symmetric
spaces and it was that's my first
introduction to professor helgesson and
it was an interesting time talking about
it earlier it is that excitement of his
singer and my Katya had announced the
index theorem a couple of years before
the DAAD and published the proof
February's waiting for the profit was
just a thing you know Halligan was doing
all the great work about analysis on
manifolds and it really his book on
symmetric space that found it sort of
you modern Riemannian geometry in the
way it should be done how did you break
geometry art and was starting to get
going was really really excitement and
of course right in the middle of things
was her Siegel and there she was sitting
I was saying earlier there was a force
of nature never would sit if there's a
seminar as interest he'd sit in the
middle and make negative comments that
we disagreed with there's a lecture but
it was really it as an interest and
fascinating players the thing that
really struck me about MIT and it's a
still and Mark and I'd mark-ass never
talked about it earlier I didn't
remember we've got four I remember going
to Harvard I don't want to knock another
institution is a wonderful institution
but up and talking to the students there
they had less interaction with the
faculty and MIT had and there were sort
of two reasons for that
and MIT math department has this
incredible commitment to education in
the broadest sense
Arthur Maddock took owned the calculus
course you took calculus in MIT and
probably still you don't take it from
some ta you get it from the real math
it's a hugely important tradition so
what is a fun play as a student to be in
the accessibility I also think I know
the hand then of the math department
here it's building toes and the one who
spend all her some money fixing it up
but the actual shape of that physical
plant I think led to part of that
intimacy because you could walk down the
corridor and the faculty was there
unavailable it is really remarkable it
was an incredible experience so I
started working my thesis I went to
Professor Helgeson and said well I'd
like to do something you know as well
you know one you take there's so many of
stuff I said I did some stuff well gone
if you take geodesics and the manifolds
the extreme points and start from the
round of that sort of so I did and I was
doing some interest and stuff and you
know begin the noodle around with it and
one day I happened to be going through
the stack in the library I was I
probably suffered from a DD but and I
saw this thing called emergent but zero
tight emergence now I want a fascinating
promote was interest me and as a kid I
said you knew even before any other but
topology that if I drew a circle like
that it was a circle on the first
circuit like that was a circle how do
you tell the difference mathematically
the curvature stuff so it was always
fascinated by the concept of shape so I
started to look at this stuff and wasn't
doesn't make much progress but really
was interesting so just before Christmas
first head wasn't said well you know
Kelly you know you you've got a thing
again out of here and what happened the
before I my supporting rod and I was
teaching at Boston College two or three
courses and pushed back later
and I said why he said I said well I
plan to get out this year he said but
you don't have anything done yet and I
said well I've got a week off of
Christmas we're gonna get a lot done and
he laughed I was of course through 24 or
something I came over on his 19 so it
still is quite young and looking back it
was a ridiculous thing to say but I
happened to be Debbie was out one night
and I was feeding Sonya Sonya was about
a year and a half as I remember I was
feeding her rice and right in the middle
of feeding her it was like a flash I saw
the answer to my problems just oh I mean
read from and I sort of explained
quickly a Japanese guy had shown that
you could take a certain type of space
News and groups emerged it on this tight
and almost like it was in society said
you know that immersion the term you can
reverse that if you have that immersion
that's if you have and it was turned out
the very important thing called a second
fundamental form people don't want to
talk but had a very trivial
representation and algebraically I
proved that got it done so so I've
decided all excited run to see professor
Allison and he said read it up let me
see it well I have a lousy handwriting
so I decided the word and rent a
Selectric Sandra Morris electrics was
the old IBM with a little changeable
ball and I sat for almost two days
straight one finger type in my thesis
and I brought him to see how I guess and
and he called me in the next day he said
I can't read this he said this is typing
his awful he said go back and do it by
hand so I'm back and did it and I ended
up so I was and my in my defense at the
end of the year there was is the singer
on row good when I was nervous good
album and I said the problem is
considered a manifold and there's the
singer said I'm manifold compact
connection can I match so I did that was
Advent pretty well at Missy's got a
Donna was feeling good and it was a
tough time for an academic life the
physics job market a felon off the table
about the year before mass was pretty
pretty tight and I went right a few
places I'd been teaching in Boston
College I wasn't gonna get there and I
got a job and Holy Cross great Holy
Cross
close enough Debbie's from central
Massachusetts a you know come to MIT for
seminars it'd be really great and you
know it's often so I think about it
roads not taking Han I ended up there it
is possible you never know how life
would have been going back to there you
know stimuli that it would have been
contempt and you know sort of get into a
rhythm of life but this was so but the
start of May this was during the
Vietnamese war now I just digress a
little about the Vietnamese war and how
they sort of think about it
people in our generation are very
affected by it I recall I came over in
1965 so 1964 Christmas watchin BBC news
at home and they showed a firefight in
the Mekong Delta and I remember clearly
the newsreader said the interesting
thing with this firefight that was the
first one as real
he didn't stage it for TV think about
that war the reporting had been staged
until then so I can cross and by that
time I said we'd Sonia and I didn't
worry about it his teacher and a family
you don't get drafted a teacher and
family but then they eliminated all the
deferments and they assigned draft
numbers by random my draft number was 52
and in the middle of May a single middle
of May I got a call from the draft
advisor which is very important position
call me I was at Ted your draft numbers
52 are you going to graduate you're
going to Vietnam I don't carry said
politically they're taking any foreigner
within three months I don't care what
degree you have you'll be in the jungle
in Vietnam he said you got to leave the
country not being a citizen and so now
it's been [ __ ] endemic life in there in
middle of May no job and we've heard
about a job in Fredericton New Brunswick
Canada so we drove up in Memorial Day
Debbie and I to New Brunswick how he
dropped Sonya off with her folks her at
a house up and having beach it was 85
degrees I mean I ride like the summer
clothes on it was we arrived in New
Brunswick it was 26 degrees but they had
a job so he took the job in New
Brunswick and was up there I started
doing some mathematics saying and
looking at I redid my thesis and the
thing that have been done algebraically
I was able to get a more geometric more
intuitive geometric proof although I
love the algebraic proof for lots of
reasons
in a sense purely algebraic proof and
illustrated to me the wonders of algebra
and geometry I mean it introduced beard
geometric so in some sense was not as
pure but it was if as good as assemblies
and understand for geometers and I was
doing some emergency and Jim Simon had
done his big work on emergence and the
annals about a hundred some on
differential operators and stuff so I
started looking and got some stuff you
know I ended up with a little thing
about the Kohala G of minimal emergence
was but the torus was innocent but not
much but I knew beyond to get
dissatisfied and in Brunswick was not
you know what I hope hoped it was a
wonderful play it's one you know it was
it was great it was God's country and
all that sort of stuff and my one
experience up there was an interesting
insight in the mathematical education
how I'd been there shortly in the head
of the Parkman and says Ted one of the
obligations we have to the state
province is we once a year we give a
they have a the teachers of the province
meeting Newcastle and we send a
professor up to talk about in
mathematics go talk so indomina that had
this sort of thing I forget who had it
sort of points and lines very simple
axioms you can develop pretty interest
in geometry I thought it'd be perfect
for territory and maths so I'm sitting
in on rooms about twenty or thirty and
right in the front seat as a guy weighs
about two hundred and seventy pounds so
I'm talking and suddenly I hear this
loud snoring true story loud snore and
he just fought fell fast asleep so
that's the that's that started eleven
Brigid 12:30 go launching her to come
back to more of this so I'm sitting very
quiet in the corner the cafeteria and
three three women came over they look
really old it must mean 45 but I think
that kinda saying wonders join you mr.
Kelly you know I was sure and say won't
apologize for whatever his name was
James James teachers shop and has
nowhere else to go with the math
department master thing so now you have
to go back in and it was just a disaster
and but
it was it was an interesting place and
but wanted to get out and I let I was
done in Boston went over dropped in to
spend a couple of hours with Professor
Hal Gerson and again he said there's not
much going on but as I have your name
had no night again
in their tears middle of May phone call
my phone rang and I said hi and said
this Ted Kelly there and I said speaking
said you've never heard of me your name
is Debbie hemo from my university Louis
and I said no I said Professor hugginson
says you may be looking for a job and I
said yeah I am I said well it's an end
of the academic year and you can't we
need a we have a problem and the deal is
you've got to get permission from your
Dean to leave even interview because
we're not going to stick your university
at the end of the earth without an empty
slot and the second part of the differs
day you got them done on Monday and
those are not an academic life an
interview consists of given a lecture in
your research go to him done on Monday
and we were on the following condition
we will decide if we want you and you've
got to be one to say yes or no so I went
to the Dean in Friday morning he said it
was a great city you love it went on on
two o'clock Monday afternoon I called
them and said we rented a house deficit
River and we had it the syllabus
wonderful city and but the the somewhere
along that way the joy in my they know
the satisfaction was getting mathematics
that little Nexus was was freedom and
actually started through some pretty
good mathematics I was talking I was
talking to there I was looking at some
stuff on things called grass man and man
for metaphors and matrices in had an
insight into other stuff and wrote quite
a long paper submitted for a publication
and got a response that it was
overlapped with some stuff a Japanese
guy did that sort of God and yet already
but in the meantime I had decided I was
going to do something else what are they
going to do so well the first thing was
I could join the NSA was looking for
Matthew
not dissimilar for Jim salmon there but
I said you know if I'm gonna do
mathematics as such I want to do my own
mathematics so no so I happened to be in
Boston area again went down to see Julia
times have changed I went down to the
police from the department used to be
over on M Street and said I have a PhD I
want a job outside and said well you've
got a job yeah I'm an assistant
professor University in Missouri and the
woman said we never had this happened
before you have never had a PhD in
mathematics come look for another job
that's changed radically since and I
said well as the statistician they need
a statistician over Gillett so it over T
lad was fifteen thousand five hundred
dollars a year I was making twelve
thousand five hundred seem like a
fortune so an infant interview and I
came out and I said no way I'm going to
work for this I just couldn't do you
work and so didn't know what to do then
I heard somebody talk about being an
actuary and I didn't know what I'm
actually didn't but I knew if you were
an action that said of you and actually
you get paid to pass exams
I knew her could pass exams so I'd went
off to take the exam I didn't have taken
sin Lewis because my students would be
there I flew up to Kansas City and the
first test was calculus now I started
calculus typical British dad form purely
formality form of calculus twelve years
old I've been doing calculus for thirty
so i sat there and there was three i
8080 question multiple choice I did a
backwards forwards plenty of time I
proved that all the answers were I
didn't weren't wrong ones than it was to
film around finished but an hour but no
I mean it's not boast I mean any any
half-decent Avenue kind of done it and
then about 20 minutes ago I said at the
mark in there things and it was a number
of 57 I think it was and I realized at
mismarked
I never broke at her to call Shweta from
back to the front and find of his number
20 or something
barely got the thing finished in time
passed the exams passed the other exam
I'm again done for a job so what
insurance well the only thing I knew but
insurance for two things about insurance
if you go to MIT what are the two things
you know but insurance
you look across the river you see the
hancock and prudential that's what I
knew about insurance literally so I
called the Hana Coggins we're not hiring
that took care of that I called the
Prudential and said well this is not an
office this is a sales office you got to
go to Newark New Jersey I knew I didn't
want to go to Newark New Jersey so I
opened the yellow pages and fortunately
Aetna happened to be the top of the
yellow pages there cut of it happily I
mean it's true I call which I turned out
later to be a little local office in
Worcester and they said I'm actually I
think that's the home office job so
ended up getting the job and I went to
the head of the department said ray
Debby him was about to go I'm leaving
San Juan I said I'm going become an
actuary said where you going
said what are you going I'm going to
Edna he says what Elise is a big company
and I went home and said to Debbie you
know what there's a big company I mean I
was a total nave I didn't know anything
and I was there and after about a year
you said to myself you know I work
really hard I could become an assistant
vice president one day you know I never
did become assistant vice president I
skipped it sooner but it was it was a
great experience
now go back how's things over time one
of my best friends
when is MIT was working at a thing
called Project Mac in Kendall Square
multi-access computing it sound so
primitive in the state of online
computing the idea that you could have
more than one person access the same
core there's the one time so I got to
Etna a wonderful boss he said okay we
have this computer and it's tied into
the mainframe do it so I started doing
some stuff and I do remember well there
was a sigh but I said that was 74 but
Airy 75 there was a notice came out
today 100 people were didn't use online
term on the computer at the same time
it's almost unconceivable how much
things have changed so I just again I
have some really great lessons one of
the first jobs out there
well first major job after look at some
reserves a kind initiative and it's
different then I got a whole pile of
hollows and carriage I'll punch charge
low to my cart wheel him down to the
computer center knocking the door went
in a little knob nowadays he can do
their computer sending under through six
security whatnot and load them up and
the results can be looking funny there's
supposed to be a balance sheet for that
area of about 300 million and he kept
calm knighted but 175 so he said I'm
making mistake
I kept looking and looking and looking
and then I realized remember honey ever
do punch cards there was an over punch
missing on every in mind over $10,000 so
the whole of mind was I'd been on stated
for years for over a hundred million
dollars which is big amount of money so
I I was common sense enough to wait
until every gun home when to my bosses
that nobody reserves are wrong by over a
hundred million dollars you don't have
something to take a boss and he said
fine we're gonna fix it
lesson right there it wasn't hided it
wasn't looked the other way it was fine
we're gonna fix it
that was a great lesson and so I did
okay if things moved along pretty well
and got different jobs and at one stage
I was in the pension department doing
we're taking in very large deposits and
I was looking to some of these large
deposit in the guarantee and I had this
inside one day you know what we're doing
there is a really sending a bond at face
value and if it's a bond that fierce
value you got to understand activity and
I better understand black Scholes theory
and do some pricing and I went off on
Gotti I heard Doug ID'd him with keen
and read that for a little bit and look
the black Scholes and I said published a
little internal paper said you know if
interest rates change suddenly we're
going to have massive losses causes of
all the optionality we're gonna be free
options and I published a paper and I
remember somebody saying
can't happen well as Alan Mendelssohn
here it did happen but five years later
it happened in speeds and it was just
not just for Aetna but for the whole of
the pension business so I was sort of
sort of sort of thinking to myself you
know this isn't isn't very good things
are bad but I would did ok cooking part
of a very large part of Aetna I was
running well and management change and
there's a little bit satisfied and one
day I was at my desk and the phone rang
I used to answer my own phone then and I
said hi Ted you don't know a.m. there's
a guy called both sake I've got a job a
lady come talk so he said go to go to
Liberty so he ended up in Liberty I met
with Gary condom and then CEO he said I
don't know what to tell you we are in
deep trouble if we don't do something
the last man I was gonna have tonight
the lights now why would anybody in the
right mind
go to a company where the guy in the
video says R&D problem well it turned
out I like Gary and I like the challenge
of turning things around the company's
worth about two and a half three billion
dollars we thought at the time what it
happened was that written a whole lot of
workers compensation medical inflation
soared and cost for a way higher than
ever an estimated in retrospect in fact
the commonly worth nothing but I joined
and things worked out very almost
immediately started get things together
I said what are two committed to you
asked one business we decided to go
international and cleanse trillion
member on the board and the board said
well take a look
so I remember well on 1994-95 we had a
guy on the board who had been chief of
capital international capital in Merrill
Lynch and he said well everybody's going
to all these places go to Central Asia
and there's some be opportunities there
so I remember getting on the plane we
flew to Tokyo visited Minister finance
there's been some time looking
opportunities Beijing member the
government there then Ellen Betar
arrived the new Lombardi to talk in the
morning met at the airport by the minute
sir of labor and population control
topic and he poured each of us a tumbler
full of it that much of street vodka and
said welcome to welcome to Mongolia as a
cold morning give you one guess as to
what the number one public health
problem is in Mongolia people falling
down drunk in the middle of street all
day long
now as I felt by the nomadic people
forced into the ugly city in the world
so we met there at the time the 94-95
with a guy the minister of get his term
but he's a little he's a physician very
mongolian logan and he was talking about
health delivery systems and that wasn't
during the Hillary care debate and he
discussed really in great detail they
the national health system the UK a
Canadian system u.s. system and Hillary
Hillary system and really really on
every anguish and we said before we
educated Moscow and he said no here in
Mongolia and one of the things the
Soviet Union did remarkably well that a
lot of things badly was educated people
in an incredible education system well
there's no money there so we flew on to
headed off to Almaty Kazakhstan and we
were the first liberties plan was the
first non-military plan ever to fly from
Ulaanbaatar Almaty ever we couldn't have
done that trip without a problem maybe
what I had to go to Moscow Moscow and
back see Raven Kazakhstan I meet some
people there and one guy we talked to I
hit a very young guy very interesting
business he was building houses prefab
houses and important from Cape Town
bring them to Kiev and shipping them to
Kazakhstan to put up housing for the oil
workers so we said how did what he did
for insurance he said well in the
maritime mana see I get normal maritime
insurance but from Kiev on I've got
fifteen hundred armed yards I don't need
insurance well we got to think this
might not be the place we want to do
business and when we were there
business disputes settled the burnt the
guy's house done now the fact that he
was tied in a chair in the living room
at the time sort of drove the point home
so we decided we weren't going to do
business in Kazakhstan so let me flew to
Tashkent and we steered in a it probably
was a modern hotel but the dust balls
were Tsarist us poles through this big
and we met were they and wonderful and
by the way he's Becca Stein they're very
hospitable because and wonderful people
and we again we said he couldn't do
business but as we were leaving we're
thinking we're pioneers he said mr.
Greenberg the Hank Greenberg aronia G
was here last week so we weren't the
only ones looking but on that trip we
did end up doing business in Japan and
China and coming back to China later on
her back to the US where he opened up in
Latin America bought a company out of
bankruptcy in Venezuela which turned out
to be
we know ensure one in every three cars
in Venezuela very big in Colombia Brazil
I'm going to China so again back to
China we go and we decided to go to top
and look at the Three Gorges project
thing insurance there and we stayed in a
city called Chongqing and we stayed in
this dump called look holiday something
it was awful and Qian Qiang at the time
it was heli city and the peasant is
coming from the countryside were yolks
across the shoulders of your bags that
can about tell fee that n we stayed in
the Holiday Inn
there's holidays something it was
recently the news the English guy who
was murdered in Chongqing was murdered
in that hotel and we ended up we got the
Chang Sheng and very successful business
and nothing to do with me we had a very
good people with very good government
relations and in fact one of the great
honors Liberty had was we hosted when
Jabbar to a large launch he because of
Liberty he chose Boston as the city
visit we hosted him
spas but twelve years ago and then was
back in China a few years later has
sitting in the Hall of Nations
you know that you see it on TV and when
JEB I was here and I'm here
this kid from Beth you know country
Northern Ireland doing talking to
primarily China he said well mr. Kelly
Porter ambitious in China I said well
I'd like to have a business maybe 600
million billion dollars said very
ambitious said what do you need through
interpreter and we're looking this way
easier and I said well we need two
things one of license in Beijing he said
well I see her doing challenging first
what else do you need
I said well as part of the business we
can't write her that at Jeannie's
partner we're gonna put Chinese partner
that was Monday Tuesday morning that
Sean change quite a bit from Beijing
Tuesday morning a guy a guy arrived in
her office in Chongqing and said I'm a
Chinese partner I'd have turned it to be
a very good partner by the way no
corruption straight down in the middle
and we were the first non Chinese
company to get a license in Beijing so
China we love Chinese replace any
business are no problems and it has been
you know interesting but then something
funny happened about nine 1990 and 2001
I was driving to the office one day and
board day and I heard the news that a
plane had hit a building in New York
they started a little session or
something and actually we were having an
audit committee meeting and glanced
really was chair and I walked in and I
said a plane hit the building New York
no big deal and then my assistant came
in and said and now the planer said I
believe it was 9/11 and we just say the
next he was aboard meanest I don't wanna
go and I can't go in to see I don't know
what's going on the board will lose
confidence so I said then we gotta come
off of the number so the number was we
said we lose one and a half billion and
it turned out we told the board one and
a half billion and probably more but
that would be reasonable I'm gonna work
with and I turned it was with 1/2
million very different we'd also want a
volunteer that year we reported out an
after-tax loss at one point seven
in an edition shortly after that with
six months when our capital is reduced
to but five billion again and the CFO
and the or chief consciously came in and
said oh by the way they're both ashen
the last thing you ever want to happen
is have your CFO and councilor come in
the same day somebody's gonna go to jail
typically that's but it wasn't they said
asbestos we have a five billion dollar
claim and well well the facts on our
side you can't trust courts where
capital was just over five billion so
we're looking so right at that point for
the second time in ten years we stirred
stirred in bankruptcy in the I so it was
an interesting process going through it
but I I was blessed with one of the best
management teams in the business and
despite that we kept I left out a
meeting when in the next door to talk
about it acquiring a company in Europe
so we kept it going we fought off
downgrading with Moody's and tried and
succeeded but a couple of other things
happen along the way that sort of an
influence at MIT well early on I got a
call from an old friend that Edna and I
said Ted I have a friend I have a a
woman I know going to Boston can you get
her a job and I said I'll send her
resume and I said by the way Alan how
are things going with you and he said
well I'm doing this thing I'm almost
finished it's happened had McLean of us
real estate problem I said what do you
want to do he said you know I really
would like to get into venture capital
so I said fine so I woke up when Bank
went down the hall today then CEO and I
said you know I got this friend great
guy really smart
totally trust where they're just one of
these guys worked with over the years
what he says is right he wants me in the
venture capital I think we should give
him 50 million dollars so I'm back and I
called on him back the next day is true
story I said Island give us a proposal I
didn't get 50 million dollars not much
more complicated and Alan took a lot of
the money did very well for us Alan as
sam mckeane
partners here and they use some of that
some of the profits set up the Kelly
scholarship fund around the math
department so thank you Alan so no good
deed goes unrewarded just thank you so
it's sort of interest in my life and
then of course I don't know if Isaac
shift came a very good friend of ours
Mass General and I meant to do I sort of
think about the and how does that
intersect with what I did well I did the
rat on transform and the Moran transform
when it volunteer City helgesen talks
about if you take a plan on can you on
your swimmin forget it sort of you've
got this amount of information and you
slice across it can you reconstruct the
total from the information in the slice
and the answer is you can reversing that
it's really right on transfer reverse
that process and that is the underlying
theory for MRIs cleaner slices and then
reconstructing the whole so there is a
sort of a it was in her life those
trajectory keeps going one way it ends
up influencing other way and it all
comes back different times really good
people got involved in my life I one of
the great people was my wife Debbie
incredible support she was willing to
take the risk with me professor
helgerson took you on as a student and
encouraged me one I probably we're
probably in the end was not I mean it
was the odds my getting the Don Merlot
supported me got me the job to move from
Canada San Louis
so it is with great pleasure that I can
recognize some of the people and here
today and thank them for the help along
the way
thank you
so I'm Ted is willing to answer a few
questions part about doing things they
had one of the best friends or bankers
[Laughter]
no I and I still have come a long way
I'm on the board
the one thing banks did that cause the
problem if you think about the
difference between what an insurance
company does and what a bank does when
we started if we started a strategic
planning for the following year that's
supposed to start in July the first
thing we did was to say what will put us
out of business
what would put us out of business we
started to that part and I'll digress a
little about that in a minute
what will put us out of business and you
protect against that then you agree to
grow banks sort of say how do we make
more money on risk it's a very different
thought process and they also so but if
you see a what'll put us out of business
the Black Swan event becomes party a
thought process for example there are
all these models and the models say for
an insurance company if you get because
there's statistical models and you know
if you get a 10% of a northeast
hurricane and 15% of a new bad Reid
earthquake etcetera etc
you're gonna lose you know four billion
dollars well you don't have ten percent
of a hurricane or 15 percent of an
earthquake you have to look at if we
have an earthquake does it cost us so we
live approach to business very much like
that whereas banks run these models
which I don't believe they understood so
in fact they were much further out in
the teal and they ever thought so on the
tail hit they had no recourse I think
that is fundamentally what happened the
other thing is and this island remember
this you learned when I was out at night
we had a thing called we did we called
it portfolio insurance and it was a
hedging day and it was non prayed was
college insurance there wasn't sold as
an insurance products was investment
product well in 1987 I remember the
October collapse market well if you have
a hedge there's one thing you need an
investment you need somebody to buy on
the other side if the liquidity dries up
the risk goes nuts and that portfolio
insurance product didn't protect
people's portfolios it doesn't hurt at
being on product so we were exposed them
to the thing the other thing is that
this is sort of you look back I mean
people just don't remember lessons we
left Connecticut in 1992 had we sold our
house in 1991 we would have gotten 50%
more than we gotten we did sell it one
year so the idea that housing costs
couldn't fall dramatically was nuts and
in fact I did another story I was just
talking about the the risk in banks and
I think I think we have told history in
that lecture I was playing golf one day
and 2007 and I turned to the caddie and
I said he carry much his there's no a
mortgage broker so I'm and then the next
is true and then the next day at work
and I call the chief investment office
and I said something's wrong let me tell
you he said we're going to talk to you
about that
so we because he didn't like was go in
the market he wouldn't we exited the
stock market at the end of 2007 saved
mr. Dawlish
the other thing was right after 9/11 in
this back thinking about risk we're very
different from banks
which I said cost us his billion left
half with three on the writers are in a
building and West and said where else
there was a lot of concentration and
they said they looked at our map New
Orleans so they got in the plan flew Don
and walked the levees talked to the Army
Corps of Engineers and there's a report
in my desk that says not if when I think
about if three mid-level underwriters
from New England could tell that there's
going to be a disaster in New Orleans
whoever the Army Corps of Engineers and
by the way Katrina was not a natural
disaster the hurricane had long gone it
was a disaster of bad engineering the
levees collapsed it was a disgrace so a
country that ignores this resin and I
think the large extent the banget which
doesn't do anymore they lowered the risk
for the same sort of reason so it's it's
their approach to risk is very different
yeah a couple of messages the first
thing remember the best teacher your own
mistakes and the second thing is learn
from other people I and one of the
things I learned very early on I was I
just started in at night and I was
assigned a research project and it
consisted of going on looking at
microfiche many ever had to put the
honor of looking at microfiche you know
I haven't done of the bars the
organization and after about ten minutes
given my attention span I said I'm not
gonna do this no I'm not only getting to
the job and having to be a little old
lady she must have been fifty but I mean
it's me I was young and I said do you
know what's on here and she did on a
project that would have taken me days
took me a couple of hours with her help
there are two things I learnt there that
served me grid one the people of doing
the job is very bottom an organization
the me and a lot of the
bandwidth but they know their job and
they're committed do it right and the
second thing was I had a friend for life
I probably was the first person who ever
recognized her worth I didn't do it for
so that was a huge lesson to me so for
example a couple of years ago because of
that liberty instituted one of the most
generous bonus programs often done the
organization of any company in the
country because the people at the bottom
of the organization are the people who
do the work and I use this line and in
Sloane's Code Napoleon said there are no
bad soldiers there are only bad officers
so leadership has the responsibility to
extract the best for people and that's
the fund the second thing is you have to
have a seared clear set of standards now
I don't believe in values I think values
are an existentialist cop-out for
standards of behavior and you have to
hold the standards and hold people you
know if they violate your standards of
ethics of how you treat people they
cannot survive in the organization so
I've clear set of standards respect
people the rest follows relatively
easily
a large fraction of Mainers to be doing
in defiance they're going to every
summer they're going to ensure
internships at Wall Street Kenna vendor
sonam when I was very unusual when I
joined but right now and Liberty we have
at least two other mathematics PhDs
when a guy called Eric Brosius who
actually was at MIT for a while then
taught her Wellesley for years he's an
algebraic geometry and the guy who runs
our polish company Micah's rinsky was in
the Advanced Studies for a couple of
years so we actually do have some pretty
good mathematicians I you know it's sort
of did you call algebraic geometry up no
no so we do get people it's pretty we
didn't we you know we will provide very
attractive incomes to people but you
know for a young person and in fact mark
and I would tell them that earlier the
allure of their quick money in Wall
Street is you know very much and I think
that pension was going to eventually
swing back but the the key you know it's
sort of people ask me for advice at
career advice I always feel a little
given career advice but a couple of
things never do something for money if
you do the right thing and you get the
money that's appropriate and wardie and
- it was not fun do something else so I
think a lot of people who do end up in
wall street find out after a couple of
years isn't that much fun and but in the
meantime to make a lot of money so yeah
it's going to the pendulum will swing it
that's just the nature of the free
enterprise system
you know we'll eventually figure I were
paying too much money somewhere and move
it elsewhere you know the government
will screw it up and tries to do it but
they were fair to praise this will do it
yeah
we you know sort of we I'm in the hole
first first of all I will say the
following Liberty because we believe
strongly the free enterprise system are
probably only one Allah company AIG and
we are so insistent that the privates
there's enough capital in the worldwide
market to solve the problem we do not
want government intervention it'll screw
it all up I know you just an aside just
to say given government invention
there's think on the National Flood
program it's vastly underfunded and it
was a start started originally who got
flooded out the the wealthy built on the
hill and the poor were stuck on the
floodplain
and the poor again and wiped out by
flood they couldn't afford insurance so
they had a flood program and the purpose
of the flood program was to help after
floods relocate the poor that was the
purpose but what happens in a democracy
who votes the middle class within two or
three years the middle and upper middle
class were using the flood program to
build houses in the Outer Banks and
please they shouldn't be building houses
so the problem we have in the u.s. some
less less so in Europe is because of
government support of bad of bad things
we have a whole lot of houses built in
areas that are very exposed to global
warming so we need to start with drawn a
little bit have better huh and force
building codes and not insure people
they live in wrong places and but it'll
it will change it but it's very great
change gradually I mean you know we keep
looking to the tornados and everything
in fact the year I moved Aetna and 74 it
was tornadoes like we had last year so
it's not some of these things are not
the longer-term trend but there will be
we will see it and you know this is
clearly where some as the ice caps begin
the shrink we're going up more flooding
and whatnot so it's going to require a
concerted effort to get people off the
shores out of bad places
it says it's very simple it's all people
it is all people as people recognize the
biggest problem is managing especially a
young manager is you think people
respond to the same stimuli and it sends
you to yourself and learn how to treat
each person differently and what and
figure out what motivates them is the
single biggest challenge you know when I
was coming up through the organization
years ago if somebody said to me a very
wise thing he said when your bottom or
halfway up an organization you wonder
where all the opportunity is between the
top of the organization you wonder where
all the talent is and it really is
getting a motivating the right people
that's that is all is it's all about
people it's all about people funny story
but this is just emergent technologies
turn to stories back in the dot-com era
I've been a young guy Britany young guy
huh burner is department and he called
me one day said it got to come talk to
him he sat down it said everything we're
doing is wrong he said the Internet's
gonna change everything we got to change
everyone doing right now and I said Bell
fine when we had and about six months
later he called Ted I've got this great
opportunity I said what is that he says
I'm going to be the chief operating
officer of a new comic-con company I
said if it goes well I'm gonna make huge
amounts of money and I said well what
would she advise I said bill you're a
young guy you're in your early 30s you
have an opportunity if you think it's
real - go for it so he called me about
three months later so I want to come and
introduce my CEO and this is he said I
said what's your business model and the
best I could free the business model was
the CEO would create buzz and that was
it this is a brother come from so
roughly by that time we had a consulting
company he kept saying you gotta worry
about that come get back technologies
and I say yeah you know he said tell you
what we will bring in our partner small
of the words who are involved in
technology unless meet I said fine I'll
build myself no one I my staff there
so the brought about 10 11 people in a
sitting on a big table and the pronin
are and a half presentation dog
so slides none of the inset and so Ted
there are at least 17 companies
attacking you from the dot-com space
right now
and I said good it was wanted be worried
thinking because they were gonna
background who says for bank run so it
turned out it was a bust
however that haven't been said there's a
whole lot of thing I give you I give you
a little lesson on what worries me I'm
an honest really we have three
grandchildren Debbie and I were over in
the fall helping her daughter do
something well not Sunday afternoon we
watching a football game and I suddenly
noticed that three grandchildren left
and where we are in the family revenue
and they they were a lot of a room is
sitting on the on the couch the oldest
who's twelve sitting in the middle and
his system was said and the youngest on
the other side and they were watching
little video on an iPhone and they had a
big screen TV and from them so already I
mean you can see how we all consume
information is already out of date each
of us people coming up behind this not
too far are going to consume information
and expect that information to be
totally different and we have got to be
constantly in our constantly experiment
with how to do it it's going to the
technology they build is a big dot I'm
an EMC board big dot as the whole thing
right now to take unstructured data
extract and from a useful information
about structured data huge issue use
probabilistic theory for filling in
empty data how that data is used and by
the way the users of the data will not
be the actuaries and they invest in
people today people who will get you
know information in a usual way so it's
gonna show all I can see is this corner
we're investing a lot of money I working
with MIT on it all we can do is you know
constantly experiment and we're gonna
make a lot of mistakes but let's hope
along the way the red one but it's going
to totally I mean I there was a huge
less than me watching my grandchildren
you know when they're ten years from now
they're their whole way of using that of
the whole way approaching the world be
so different many many of us do and we
just it's going to be a it's exciting
and almost
writing to him so I don't answer your
question yeah planned not planned in the
sense of was a good question
no not planet all I never dreamed of
being the CEO of a company but once I
got in I said plans but Debbie and I
always had some things we shared we
beating he shouldn't be together we'd do
the best thing for a daughter or do it
we could take advantage of opportunities
you know sort of somebody asked me after
retired how much influence luck had on
my career and I'm gonna give you a
strange answer the best thing ever
happened to me was bad luck because it's
how we handle the bad luck and made the
90-degree turns where things went wrong
it led to where we were it is you know
when the job disappeared here because of
Vietnam we didn't collab in fact it we
give you an example different Society of
how things could have been different
Jean Carlo rota was the air at the time
and I was at home just before went up to
Canada I got a call I said hi Ted just
Karen Colorado I understand they need a
job this is I said yeah I said well
there's a group of people over backward
or we'd like to come talk to them so I'm
and off to meet them and there are three
relevant guys and they said we're trying
to hire the head of the math department
for the National University and we've
got a huge budget and we'd like to do it
you know sort of just new PhD head of a
department and I said the money's going
this amount of money which is I forget
was 19 thousand dollars you can live
like a king in Ecuador and by the way
we'll give you a thing you can fly your
family to home back to the US twice a
year and I said well what about the
political situations they said most
stable government in Latin America had
the same governments the name of 47 well
I'm at home and Debby Niger said very
you want to go to Ecuador and by the way
the government collapsed when a military
coup over two months later not because
we didn't go there there's a lot of
reason but so you know how we responded
too bad I'm really saying how we respond
to the things going wrong worthy where
the important things to determine that
things were right so bad luck is much
more important and healthy than good
luck see good luck you think you caused
it bad luck you know you gotta deal with
[Applause]